early in the morning usually from a
you know this type of innovama you'd
you'd sleep on the tatami you quickly
roll up your your bed six o'clock in the
morning you go outside and you sweep and
prepare it's like a raking so and then
you you sweep this area outside and you
get it all ready
and all nice and smooth
and then you go out there it's odd if
you get there to mess it up because you
go out there and train weapons
seven o'clock in the morning seven for
one hour
if it's raining they do taijitsu in the
dojo
and then that's hard first thing in the
morning because the the mats like
concrete it's really a hard old map
so to get through you do that then you
do your training then you quickly rush
back to sleep
and you and you eat sleep train and
that's about the life that's a
doesn't seem much of a life but that's
the life you have to do you have to eat
a lot sleep a lot and then you can train
hard in those those hour periods
and I enjoy hard training but there's a
way of talking about hard training so
when you train hard
you can train like this
now for one hour of doing that that's
hard training
or you can train okay
that's physical hard but you're not
getting it and that's the zero plus zero
method you're not getting anything out
of it you just
swinging up and down
but you're not having time to study what
your body should be feeling
and that's why I've just gone through
the process about each Sleep Train hard
so you have to have the right
proportions of each thing so when
training you have to have the right
proportion on
what that that key eye and that pausing
is giving me chance to think
when it was coming over my head it waved
a little or you might be here oh you're
thinking I'm off balance but uh I'll try
and correct it next time
you're sending yourself messages
now in the western
uh Society they do this they go hey
they try and adjust it afterwards you
can't adjust it afterwards it's okay
trying to find the place
but the place is gone
you were there wrong it it happened it
went
ah if you go like that there's no good
trying to
save yourself
hoping nobody saw you they saw you and
you felt it so when this happens ah
you have to do that just to save
yourself but keep your sanction keep
still
but don't go I should have been here and
then does everybody understand what I
mean don't try and adjust too much
each time
okay so we all spread out across the
this way
take the can
depend on the
ah this foot must point at my partner
Center
have a nice form
a nice form and go back in a nice way as
well
observing your partner
oh
we're doing Shanghai what means
three senkai means change now everybody
has a problem on knowing how to teach
each other how to change
so we'll pretend we've uh
we've done two already
I usually do this
ah
[Applause]
and sometimes they don't see you nod and
sometimes they don't see you nod so I
usually go
because just that little moment
everybody sort of knows that means
change around so you just go
because they're usually observing you if
you go they might think that it's time
to pick up you see they might think it's
time to attack you again so you go
don't let your partner know when you're
coming
this will make his ancient what is his
awareness cooker
that's like that
okay
so it's not so much
have it it's quite funny it's quite
amusing it's it's good uh it's good
spirited to try and catch him out but
you shouldn't try and do it in I'm a
higher grade than him and I'm better
than him even if you're the same grade
you know there's no equalness about I'm
a lower grade name and I made him Shake
because I out speeded him in the end it
will bring both your levels up so please
don't use it like tricking
try and use it as budo my face shouldn't
change
he said I'm there and he has to really
then start to learn
where I'm gonna go if if he knows that
you're tricking him
he'll start he'll start twitching
thinking that he's coming he's coming
and by the time I ah actually come he
can't move because he's been busy trying
to
so we have an understanding
here's the understanding
I'm very still
same expression
each neat slow
pause long enough to make it sensible I
we start this numbers now I usually
think if you count to five
each new San she goes
the cat is what you want fast not the
trickery
Okay so
senkai kotai